you just punch this kid one time but he
hurt him pretty bad yeah let me pull my
note so his name's Michael lo have you
heard of him I had not okay so Michael
Loeb in the nineties I'm pulling up my
notes he started this thing called
synapse group and basically what they
did was this was before a lot of things
were popular on the Internet and so they
patented I don't know how they did this
there must been something unique about
it but they patented this online
subscription model I don't yeah I don't
know like how that there's some really
needy gritty things that are a little
bit beyond what I'm able to understand
but well so they they just create a
unique way to do it and I think I don't
know exactly how it worked but basically
Time magazine Meredith which is a huge
magazine publisher all these magazine
publishers would pay them money to get
them more subscriptions because this way
in which they were able to get people to
renew subscriptions must have been
fantastic and it worked really well I
don't understand how it worked then
basically what it seems now is like a
really robust affiliate network so like
Meredith will cross sell Meredith which
is a three billion dollar company based
out of Minnesota I believe bought the
company synapse for a lot of money and
they deployed it across all their brands
so it's kind of he made it big through
the synapse group which was a magazine
subscription thing yeah it definitely
made him wealthy he didn't make him a
billionaire but it made him he
definitely got wealthy what made him
really wealthy was with his co-founder
of synapse he wasn't sort of Christ
flying and Priceline eventually I think
are they are they owned by Expedia or
they don't think I'm not sure let's just
check it out looking looking so it now
it's just a huge you know huge thing so
that made them very wealthy but what's
interesting is after that he started
like the what used to be part of just
like a rich entrepreneurs playground
where they just launched companies right
it's called Loeb and Loeb
NYC and they've started a whole bunch of
companies including a company called
I believe it's called scrip relief do
you know what that is no so what you do
is you go to it they started companies
like or they use this they used to own
script relief and then they renamed it
just something else but basically what
you do is you go to the website and you
can get discounts off of your
pharmaceutical drugs and so like if you
want to buy if you have Zanna X or some
type of acne medicine or something like
that somehow they they they get access
to these deals and use that coupon code
at CVS and you get a discount and it's
paid for sending CBS business and they
made that business we talked about on
the podcast call thanks that B to be
gifting things looks like it's in their
area and a business like script relief
was making something like one hundred
million dollars a year in profit and so
song as companies are really big now
here's another reason why he's
interesting do you ever watch that TV
show billions yep love it you know the
house at Bobby Axelrod okay yes that's
his house that's Michael Loubs house
okay last year or two years ago Michael
Loeb had a big party like a fundraiser
like a sophisticated thing and his son
brought some friends along and some of
the 18 year old friends got drunk and
started kissing on the front new on and
just looking like a fool and soullow
punched one of the kids in the nose and
broke his nose and might go to jail for
it he just punch this kid one time but
he hurt him pretty bad
he's in jail for just that they're
they're trying to get him to go to jail
for that I mean that's assault
if you Burt if you hurt someone even if
you weren't a billionaire you definitely
could go to jail for that they're trying
to get him to go to jail I have a
feeling he's just gonna write a fat
check I mean yeah the kid was it's
probably just a rich snobby so where'd
you see this scripps thing there's not
even on their website I talked to people
who worked there uh Sam do his thing
investigative journalist Sam I like it
just talk to people who work there so if
you google and let's see Michael Loeb
Google Michael Loeb script relief it's
it's on his LinkedIn yeah I see it now
it's renamed something else though dude
say what it's renamed - I'm checking but
you know it's logging into LinkedIn is
like you know taking the first 10 steps
into hell so I'm gonna try this now
scrip relief was recently sold to United
Healthcare over 5 million users yeah so
it was sold to someone else and now it's
called something else but he just has
like a web of companies and he's just
super interesting because this is gonna
sound weird when you look at this guy do
you do you think this guy looks like a
billionaire does this guy look like a
successful guy no that's why he doesn't
he looks like a guy who would punch a
kid in the face yeah he looks like a guy
who's like bitter about his life and
punch the kid in the face for that
reason not punch a kid in the face
because he's a billionaire and the kid
pissed in his pool oh he looks like he
would be punching kids in the face
regardless of what his financial status
was that's why he's interesting to me so
I have such a good mugshot google his
name he looks like he looks like a tough
guy yeah he looks yeah he looks like a
tough guy he looks like an enforcer that
a billionaire would have he's a building
up he looks like a billionaires enforcer
yeah that's why I think this person was
interesting because it was dang they
have a picture of the kid who punched I
[Laughter]
did not expect to just see those two
side-by-side that's yeah this is quality
this is quality Google is searching it's
good right look at that kid he
definitely has a Punchbowl whole face
yeah well the kid looks like he did
something he's even he's like kind of
smug in the picture he's a broken nose
he's in the hospital shirts covered in
blood he's got a little smirk on him
yeah super interesting person right yes
okay I like this guy I never even heard
of this guy I feel like you know a bunch
of these guys that are like the either
media Titans or like these other like
New York you know New York rich people
barely know like San Francisco or like
Dubai rich people I know them because I
spend time I'm on Wikipedia because my
way of building businesses is I'd like
to see what has worked and I I reverse
engineer how it worked
and I'm like all right I'm gonna deploy
that on my company right and when I'm
reversing name things I'll like read
about the company right well I'll see
who started it and I'm like no way that
guy started it
oh but he was friends with this person
and they partnered previously I bet he
had access to that's probably how so
like I like
under so you I just like
reverse-engineer things yeah I like that
and then you call people which most
people don't do you get off the phone
you start calling people work at the
company you get that extra 10% that you
needed right that's of helps because oh
I've made friends someone who started
his thing so now if I want to meet him I
I have it in right
[Music]